gli attenti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj ed oggi sono con il mio
vecchio quasi come avevo detto nel primo
episodio e crash vendita come aveva
fatto conoscere lui ho deciso di fare il
secondo episodio di crash pennica
appunto con lui lo ricordi si si si
legga questo sembra il danno di trono di
spade
come fai conoscere il trono di spade di
trony spade lo guardano le ragazze e tu
questa roma non ha senso vorrei comunque
titolo l'ora di iniziare guarda che non
aspetta sia salutare piazza almeno
all'inizio fa però fare a me dai mi
chiama è una vita che aspetto sto gioco
che ricordo che facevamo una partita a
testa finché non morire facciamo una
partita testa pica non moriamo anche
adesso dai quelle macchine sì ma
ricordava sta roba o accompagnare so
qual è la velocità massima che si può
tenere in autostrada papa 100 130 si
vola perfetto questo ho parlato sul
serio non sia arrivato prima fa niente
dove arriva primo ma va a minchia loro
nome risputato fuori benetton altro
incazzo datato 1 mandes tito a questo se
cos'è che ti schianti subito hai fatto
con lo faccia allora vai sul tipo
insilati grandi e vero semmai difficile
sta roba da tigre come software boss non
ci credo non sei morto subito
avrei scommesso tutto uno che volevi che
saresti molto subito e te lo giuro ho
sottovalutato un sacco
9 non ci credo
a regà non ci fossero grecia sta facendo
va bene va bene ho visto tra 6 giocato
molto di più di quanto pensassi hanno
visto il drago che arriva ti giuro che
si è durato un sacco di contatti ma chi
è che non vede un drago che arriva abbia
effettivamente io la prima volta che
gioco dopo tutto dopo 10 mikhailov in
televisione nascar se non uguale dai
perché a me ha detto non abbiamo
presente un gettone di certo male
sì ma io ho sbagliato lo schiacciatore
non mi piace
ma mi devo concentrare il drago
no eccolo dai occhio che ci devi saltare
il fosso non so se non divisa alta nel
drago di saltare il fosso che non faccio
io faccio io pensavo che ricominciamo da
prima del thè aspetta aspetta dai
tralasciato non guarda più
ok
sennò una riga ho sbagliato nuovo gioco
a me no
minchia quando sono finito e sono finito
a domodossola
beh non è che sia cambiata molto la
situazione e vabbè ma ho io faccio
questi di lavoro vedrà visto che proprio
non me lo merito suo lavoro
occhio occhio come piano me piano
mettiamo tu io corro perché sono stupido
c6 ci si arriva alla fine va benissimo
mi hai finito lui ragazzo di tutto sto
casino ha vinto ma non ci si senta nel
mio audio mamma maura a ma c'è chi piace
questo sa è uno che ti incorna perché
sono riuscite in corner
ma scusa questa questa questa è mamma
quando prendevo i quattro matematica
tali garrire questi contano a casa cosa
che non rientravo preso litro è un
rapper cos'è sta roba
chi l'ha visto che se arriva un sacco
fantastica no quelli del mondo io fa
niente occhio a nitro che che katy vista
di brutto perché non salta deve tener
premuto però non ce la fai a prenderlo
stesso prova ancora ma basta quanti 4
preso
sì va bene ma non vale cioè lui miyagi
no mi ha preso mi sembra che quando
prendeva 4 in pagella
la camminata nella stessa entravo in
casa e il verso entra entravo in casa e
nella crisi e pensa che miss qualità
talmente tanto io che mi mettevo
studiare io grandissimo incazzo porca
vacca sono vivo e prima vista questo è
difficile
secondo me non lo so è però potresti
potresti riuscirci
stavo scherzando non stavo scherzando
avviso ti preoccupare è volevi mi sono
chiarito addosso fortissimo è realtà
porca vacca questo questo è veramente un
casino e te lo dico se non vinco io non
mi ci pensate come siamo messi è un po
messina di mera vo salta bravissimo non
sui marini dove non c'è la roba check
point aveva dato un savani a in porca di
una vacca sposa poco altri stata subito
e occhio salta sinistra sinistra salta
non salta resso bravo
non lo so cosa devi fare qua occhio non
servono e c'è poi in sé mori amori
dobbiamo iniziare tutto occhi occhi
occhi occhio che prendono lo stesso va
bene
occhio occhio mi piace vinci me ne vado
bravissimo ci sta che eri arrivato così
alla fine hai fatto una roba incredibile
no arancio non ce la faremo mai più
sinistra salta di più se ti fai fai
fatti solo che questo spaventare e
schiacciato salta prima del tempo
porca vacca schifosa maledetta infame
ora che te la cavi
non giocare più da da 80 anni stava
scherzando scherza io perché tu devi
saperlo nico devo dire che devo dire di
stare zitta e ragione
ciao ciao bella ciao bella io ti conosco
tu fumi cannella ragazzi io direi che
possiamo concludere qui questo video
ringrazio mio padre che aveva
partecipato questo grandissimo gioco e
soprattutto per avermi fatto a verona ho
comprato da piccole grazie anche per
questo niente raga e stato bello
ritornare ai vecchi tempi quindi ragazzi
spero che video vi sia piaciuto cosa mi
piace anche vari social come descrizione
ciociari si rischia the rich vediamo
prossimo video da ragazzino a questo
punto perché questa del televisore su
mises cassa da ragazzi
[Musica]
ma